terry mcauliffe faces the music in
virginia encounters by playing the race
card joe manchin puts a stake through
the heart of joe biden's build back
better plan and joe biden falls asleep
during a climate change conference i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the men shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first you know black friday
is coming but you should be saving a lot
of money before black friday and that
means looking at your recurring bills
well look at your bill what are you
spending money on your cell phone
provider aren't you aren't you well go
check out pure talk to stop all of that
you want to do something smart this
month i'm going to give you the life
hack to cut your cell phone bill in half
it is indeed pure talk pure talk gives
you killer 5g coverage on one of the
largest 5g networks in the country and
still saves the average family over 800
a year i made the switch the coverage is
great their us-based customer service
actually cares about you and your tax
prices are pretty much wholesale gonna
talk text six gigs of data for just 30
bucks a month keep your number keep your
phone or this month you get black friday
prices on new phones like the iphone 12
which is 479 bucks which is one heck of
a deal they have a 30 day risk free
guarantee so you literally have nothing
to lose go to puretalk.com shop for a
plan and phone that is right for you
then enter promo code shapiro you will
save 50 off your first month and save on
a new phone that is puretalk.com promo
code shapiro puretalk is simply smarter
wireless some restrictions apply see
site for details alrighty so today is
the big election in virginia and the
polls are extremely close in virginia
according to the 538 polling average
glen youngkin is up about one point on
terry mcauliffe now there's the
possibility that mcauliffe if the
election is that close on election day
wins because of the early voting
mcauliffe is still ahead okay but
if there is a surge for yonkin which it
seems like there is because just a few
weeks ago mcauliffe was up like pretty
big if you go back to the beginning of
october the poll average had mcauliffe
up three if you go back further than
that if you go back to like august
mcauliffe was up eight
young ken has slowly but steadily closed
the gap and he finally overtook him last
week or so okay because of that young
can i think is gonna get better turnout
if i have to put money on it today i say
the young kin wins and there are some
early indicators that that is in fact
the case so for example last night in
virginia beach mcauliffe had to cancel
an event presumably because nobody was
actually going to show up according to
13newsnow.com election day is
approaching and both candidates running
for governor want to make sure people
are getting out to vote republican glenn
younkin and democrat terry mcauliffe
were both initially scheduled to hold
events in virginia beach on november 1st
but a spokesperson from a college said
he would no longer be having one in
hampton roads instead he was going to be
campaigning in a different portion of
the state the reason being more people
are going to show up for young kid than
mcauliffe and it was going to look
really bad now what the media are trying
to do is find anyone anyone in a young
crowd who looks like a racist because
they must categorize everybody voting
for kin is a racist this is the closing
pitch see the thing is this people are
not enthused about mcauliffe and no one
is enthused about mcauliffe and
democratic votes are largely predicated
on heavy black turnout these days ever
since 2012 democrats have basically
hoped to replicate the obama coalition
both nationally and in the states and
the idea there is if you get outsized
black turnout and you get sort of normal
turnout from everybody else then you'll
win elections because that's what barack
obama did in 2012. if barack obama did
not have outside turnout in places like
ohio in 2012 he does not win the
election okay so in 2020 joe biden got
extremely heavy black turnout and it
turned out very well for him right as a
percentage of the populations a
percentage of the population blacks out
voted their percentage of the population
again in 2020 but in 2021 2022 there
doesn't seem to be quite as much
enthusiasm from black voters to get out
there and vote and so democrats are
trying desperately to get black voters
out there to vote and the way that they
are doing this is by claiming over and
over and over again
that glenn young is a racist and the
media are complicit in all of this of
course because this is what they do and
so there's a picture that was flying
around the internet last night of a guy
at a young can rally who apparently had
like a brand new
jean jacket with a confederate flag
stone on the back of it like it was
brand spankin new the guy looked like he
was maybe in his 50s or 60s and no one
knows who he is nobody really knows who
he is but there's a picture of him from
behind and the media are spreading this
far and wide because if there's one
person in a 200 mile radius of a glenn
young can rally who has a confederate
flag on the back of his jacket this
means glenn youngkin is of course a
neoconfederate
now again after last week's debacle in
which you had a bunch of people from the
young democrats of virginia put up to it
by the lincoln project pretending to be
white supremacists outside of yunken
rally i have suspicions and i find it
very suspicious that nobody in the media
just went up to this guy and asked him a
few questions about who he was because
if he's going to be used as a stand-in
for all of young kids voters you might
at least want to know something about
him but um yeah so so color me
suspicious but the media have their
agenda and they have been attempting to
push it it is failing because junkin is
not a racist and also it's a little
difficult to make the claim in virginia
that the republicans are the racist when
the current sitting governor of virginia
is the guy who is either in blackface or
in the kkk outfit
right that makes it kind of rough
you're standing around going those guys
are racist like well remember that time
you wanted ralph northam to resign and
he didn't resign and then he campaigned
with terry mcauliffe that's awkward is
it not but this is terry mcauliffe's
closing pitch so terry mcauliffe is not
moving away from the radical left in
fact he is doubling down he was
campaigning yesterday with the head of
the american federation of teachers
randy weingarten who is just
terrible and awful in nearly every way
randy weingarten of course has been a
very formative factor in teachers not
going back to school and keeping kids
out of school
she has had heavy influence on the biden
administration's approach toward covid
in schools
and she's campaigning with terry
mcauliffe in the middle of an election
which mcauliffe is somehow losing the
education issue remember democrats
rarely lose the education issue why
because when it comes to education the
way people typically vote is
who pledges to signing a bigger check to
the schools but in this particular case
the actual question of what was being
taught in schools
reared its head and it reared its head
because of kovitt frankly because a lot
of people were seeing in zoom school
what teachers were finally teaching
behind closed doors and they were
disquieted by this and then when they
sounded off on it then the democrats
said how dare you care what your kids
are being taught it's our job to teach
your children so young can put forward
basically a two-prong plan one we'll
teach your kids actual stuff not
critical race theory garbage or lgbt
propaganda
and two we will fund the schools and
that turns out to be a winning message
for republicans well democrats keep
doubling down on all of their themes
their themes are give the teachers
unions everything they want and also
republicans are deeply racist and so we
must make pledges that make no sense
whatsoever about race in virginia
schools we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk about your
safety and security at home this holiday
season deck the halls walls windows and
doors with the best deals of the year on
the award-winning ring alarm i'm sure we
all know about the ring video doorbell
by now and if you don't because you
haven't been listening to the show but
ring makes an award-winning alarm as
well ring alarm is a powerful affordable
whole home security system you can
easily install yourself i did it myself
and i'm no tech whiz
whether you're running across town or
across the country this busy season you
and your loved ones can rest easy
knowing your home is protected and it's
more than just security ring alarm
protects your home from flood freeze and
fire as well plus it's a lot cheaper
than those other companies for what they
charge for one month you can get an
entire year of ring alarm with
professional monitoring right now for
the best deals of the year on ring alarm
head on over to ring.com forward slash
ben my kids are constantly running
around my property all three of them are
highly mobile and uh and because of that
that means sometimes you look away and
one of the kids is going like where'd
the kid go well this is where the ring
app comes in very useful for me even
when i'm just at home this holiday
season check the hall's walls doors
windows with that best deal of the year
on the award-winning ring alarm go to
ring.com got a great deal on a ring
alarm security kit today that is
ring.com forward slash ben alright so
terry mcauliffe making his closing pitch
and it is not good so yesterday terry
mcauliffe on the campaign trail he
complained that there are too many white
teachers in virginia right again the
idea here is black voters should show up
so that terry mcauliffe will put more
black teachers in schools as though this
is what
school children desperately need is to
adjudicate the quality of their teachers
by
their immutable skin color
makes perfect sense here's terry
mcauliffe making the case
we got to work hard diversify our
teacher base 50 of our students our
students of color 80 percent of the
teachers are white so what i'm going to
do for you be the first state in america
if you'll go teach in virginia for five
years in a high demand area that could
be geographic it could be coursework we
will pay room board tuition at any
college any university or any hbcu here
in virginia you're the first state in
america to do that okay so again
understand the case he's making there
are a lot of black students there are
not enough black teachers therefore we
have to quote unquote diversify our
teacher base we're not going to worry
about the quality of the education kids
receive we're going to worry about the
skin color of the people who are
teaching so i think that people are less
than sanguine when they hear from terry
mcauliffe
that he is not interested in pushing
critical race theory in schools because
he's literally pushing it on the
campaign trail when you say that all
inequality is a result of systemic
inequity that must be reversed by actual
discrimination right you're gonna you're
not gonna discriminate on the basis of
race and how you hire teachers people
are uh slightly untrusting here's sarah
mcauliffe then denying that the issues
people care about are even issues and by
the way he's standing next to governor
ralph northam who is uh who is not
wearing blackface today so he decided
not to do that here's terry mcauliffe
he talks about critical race theory
let's be clear folks
critical race theory has never been
taught in the commonwealth of virginia
he says day one he's gonna ban it
he's gonna ban something that doesn't
exist critical race theory doesn't exist
it's a figment of your imagination
and all of those kids who are learning
about racial essentialism in schools
they don't exist their parents don't
exist by the way it is always a very
smart plan to tell a bunch of parents
that their concerns are completely
specious that they make no sense
whatsoever in the middle of a race
you're losing
in a state that joe biden won by 10.
really good solid campaigning here from
terri mcauliffe and then macaulay goes
further right he says that young kid is
only invoking crt because he's racist in
fact if you mention critical race theory
it's because you're a racist not because
so much of our intellectual discourse
has been about critical race theory for
the past several years right talk about
white privilege which has skyrocketed in
mentions in the new york times talk
about the systemic racism of american
systems
the bleeding down of that to the lowest
educational levels which we've detailed
on the program
now all of that is really just if you're
worried about that it's because you're
racist this is the game that democrats
like to play
push an extraordinarily radical policy
and if you notice it's because you're
bad we're gonna push lgbtp
lgbtqia plus
minus sign
[Music]
percentage
carrot
right we're gonna push propaganda from
all these various groups
and then if you notice that it's because
you are a cis-normative homophobe okay
this is this is just the way democrats
like to play the game so here is terry
mcauliffe playing that game if you
notice crt it's because you're a racist
what bothers me to my core
is what this man is doing
he's dividing parents against parents
parents against school boards he's using
your children as political pawns in his
campaign it is a racist dog whistle
folks we are better than that
we will not have that hatred here in the
commonwealth of virginia
um
what now
he's wait wait gwen youngkin is being
divisive tara mcauliffe glenn younkin
you're literally standing there and
saying that everyone who votes for glenn
youngkin is basically a racist and then
when junkin is being divisive because he
says he doesn't want racial essentialism
taught in schools and it's the entire
democratic party right this this is the
only card they can play the problem is
for the democrats that they don't have
somebody charismatic and of minority
status like barack obama to call upon to
make this case
and this was the killer app for
democrats barack obama was a killer app
for democrats because obama would make
the exact same case and then people
would be like well we can't say anything
because of his race i mean because
barack obama has lived that life we are
not allowed to say anything about this
otherwise we will be considered racist
if you attack barack obama's policies
it's because you're racist if you attack
barack obama's rhetoric it's because
you're racist now they did try to try
out barack obama in this race it was
completely unsuccessful because in the
end it's terry mcauliffe who's running
not barack obama
and in the end it is joe biden at the
top of the national ticket not barack
obama
okay so but i'm sorry like this case
being made by terry mcauliffe the
whitest person outside of joe biden and
made by tim kaine who's just as white as
both it just doesn't have any sort of
actual gravitas or right here's tim
kaine trying to say that republicans are
running on resegregation or some such
nonsense
my father-in-law was the governor who
ended segregation in virginia integrated
public schools
and and he was hated for it at the time
in the 1970s he died just three days ago
and people are writing about how
courageous he is linwood was 98 years
old and he he thought that he had helped
virginia turn away from
you know dog whistles and appeals to
um segregationist attitudes uh gwen
yonkan's
preaching of the big lie about electoral
fraud and
and copying donald trump's line which he
started the campaign with and now at the
end
featuring the
uh this activist who went against tony
morrison's book beloved it's harkening
back to a day gone by in virginia
harkening back to a day gone by right
this is the entire democratic stick over
and over and over mitt romney is going
to put y'all back in chains it doesn't
work it just doesn't work anymore nobody
is buying into this especially because
we know that you're lying okay here's a
loud and county mom who testified in
front of a school board this is last
week saying that her six-year-old was
coming home asking about whether she was
evil because of the racial essentialism
being taught in her school first it was
in early spring of 2020 when my
six-year-old somberly came to me and
asked me if she was born evil because
she was a white person something she
learned in a history lesson at school
then you kept the schools closed for a
year and a half despite the science
indicating that it was safe for kids to
return and now you've covered up a rape
then arrested humiliated and falsely
accused her parents of being domestic
terrorists i wish i could return my kids
to lcps private school is expensive and
i want my kids to be able to walk home
from school with their friends in their
own community i refuse to allow you to
destroy our schools they are not your
schools they are our schools you all
should be ashamed and you should have
the moral courage to admit you are wrong
and step down okay so in one second
we'll get to more talk about critical
race theory in virginia schools because
yes it exists it does i'm sorry when
you're teaching ibramex candy children
books to small children that is critical
race theory we'll get some more on this
in just one second first let's talk
about a simple fact you know with
everybody going back to work and with
the economy beginning to open up the
lines everywhere have gotten a lot
longer that is true at the post office
as well and this holiday season you
don't want to be standing in line at the
post office because who wants to do that
post office does a lot of great stuff
standing in line is not one of those
great things instead why don't you get
all the great services of the postal
service with stamps.com and save time
and save money stamps.com lets you
compare rates print labels access
exclusive discounts on ups and usps
services all year long
it makes sense especially if your
business sends more mail and packages
during the holidays here at dailywire
we've used stamps.com since 2017 we do
not waste our time whether you're
selling online or running an office or
side hustle stamps.com can save you time
money stress during the holidays access
all post office and ups shipping
services you need without taking the
trip and get discounts you can't find
anywhere else like up to 40 off usps
rates and 76 off ups that's some great
money savings again we use it here at
daily wire because we like saving time
and money you should do the same sign up
with promo code shapiro for a special
offer at stamps.com it includes a four
week trial free postage digital scale no
long term commitments no contracts just
go to stamps.com click that microphone
at the top of the page enter code
shapiro go check them out right now so
again
the case keeps being made that
if you are a parent you're not supposed
to be worried about critical race theory
in schools you're not supposed to worry
about what these teachers are teaching
your kids at all
and yet
according to fox news andrew mark miller
reporting the phrase critical race
theory appears on the virginia
department of education website despite
tara mcauliffe's repeated claims the
curriculum is not taught in virginia on
the virginia department of education
website several examples of the
department promoting a critical race
theory can be found including a
presentation from 2015 when terry
mcauliffe was governor that encourages
teachers to quote embrace critical race
theory in order to re-engineer attitudes
and belief systems additionally
superintendent
memo05019 can be found on the site from
february 2019 promoting both critical
race theory and the idea of white
fragility also in 2019 under democratic
governor ralph northam superintendent of
public instruction james lane sent a
memo to virginia public schools
endorsing foundations of critical race
theory in education as an important tool
that can further spur development in
education
all of that via city journal's chris
ruffo who's done excellent excellent
work on this entire issue
the mcauliffe campaign did not respond
to a request for comments on the
presence of critical race theory in
virginia public schools neither did the
virginia department of education in june
officials in loudoun county acknowledged
that critical race theory influenced
their work in july it was revealed that
a virginia school district spent 30
grand on critical race theory training
for administrators and yet they continue
to maintain the lie that any parent
who's worried about this is simply crazy
that any parent who is upset about the
possibility of their children being
taught the racial essentialism
represented by critical race theory is
crazy
now again this is there's an inherent
component of critical race theory that
teaches that there is guilt that
attaches you by dint of your race the
premises of critical race theory include
that racism is not aberrational it is
part of the system it is embedded in
every system
also that it serves white interests for
racism to be embedded in every system
also that race is a social construct but
simultaneously that your racial status
in the united states gives you expertise
to speak on issues that other people
cannot speak on which is a form of
racial essentialism right all of those
premises by the way are specified by
richard delgado and gene stefanczyk who
actually wrote the critical theory the
critical race theory introduction and
premier
and yet again the case is made by
democrats that we're all supposed to
ignore this and if you don't ignore this
you're a racist it's just not going to
play it's not going to in fact i
recommend strongly that every democrat
continue to run on the basis that
everyone worried about this is crazy and
or racist
juan williams has a piece over at the
hill literally titled parents rights is
code for white race policies
okay so parents rights is code for white
race politics is the name of the piece
really so if i want
rights over how my children are educated
and raised
that's code for i'm a racist now
i thought that was code for i want to
raise my own children and i don't think
that you should be teaching values that
contradict my own
because they're my kids not your kids
and i'm delegating teaching to you
with the proviso that you not
indoctrinate them in a bunch of racially
ignorant nonsense
but here's what juan williams writes
he says now republican virginia
republicans are back with the new and
improved culture wars campaign for 2021
the closing argument is once again full
of racial division this time it is
dressed up as a defense of little
children the rallying and cry is parents
rights it's a campaign to stop classroom
discussion of black lives matter
protests or slavery because it could
upset some children especially white
children who might feel guilt okay
literally no one is saying that you
can't teach children about slavery
all we are saying is that you cannot say
that every discrepancy in american life
is brought about because the systems of
the united states are inherently evil
okay that we're saying you can't teach
because it's false but of course you can
teach kids about like honest to god i
wonder whether these people have ever
been inside a classroom of course kids
are being taught about slavery is there
a child in america who doesn't know
about the evils of slavery
i literally my seven-year-old daughter
knows about it i've talked about the
evils of slavery with my seven-year-old
daughter because she likes american
history and wants to know about it and
it's important
this this idiotic notion that if you
stop teaching critical race theory which
is a framework for seeing america as
evil and wrong and its institutions as
fundamentally flawed and sinful that if
you don't teach that somehow you're
obscuring america's history is inane
or that if you don't want other people
teaching that's your kids that that you
are therefore engaged in white
supremacist politics as juan williams is
sort of suggesting here it's crazy
says juan williams unlike their earlier
defense of confederate monuments the
parents rights campaign message at first
glance looks to have zero to do with
race
that puts democrats on the defensive
they're in the uncomfortable position of
calling the attention of suburban white
moms to divisive racial politics being
used by republican glenn young king's
campaign terry mcauliffe the democratic
candidate calls the republican message a
racist dog whistle
some of the charlottesville white
extremists are now on trial in a civil
case for their violent attacks and so we
should all remember that says juan
williams
there's a long history behind the latest
racist political appeals it wasn't that
long ago that racist southern
politicians rallied against integration
with an argument for states right wait
hold on what does this have to do with
rallying against integration it's
literally rallying on the basis of we
should treat people as individuals and
not by
didn't of skin color that's literally
the opposition to critical race theory
but it's it's
again keep running on the spaces
democrats really keep doing it i'm eager
to see how this goes for you
truly eager
they are doing this by the way and the
media are repeating it larry sabato who
used to be a much more interesting
analyst over at the university of
virginia center for politics he's doing
the same routine critical race theories
a big nonsense argument
again the idea here is that anytime you
notice a democrat doing a radical thing
you're the problem not the democratic
thing here's larry sabato making the
case that republicans are running a
racist campaign because they want to not
teach racism in public schools
the operative word is not critical
and it's not theory
it's grace but a shock huh
race
that is what matters and that's why it
sticks
there's a lot of we can call it white
backlash white resistance uh whatever
you want to call it it has to do with
race and so we live in a post-factual
era anyway chris this is a post-factual
error it doesn't matter that it isn't
taught in virginia schools it's this
generalized attitude that whites are
being put upon and we've got to do
something about it we being white voters
ah so that's what it is it's again white
supremacy now the goal here is to not
drive out suburban moms we're all going
to vote against terry mcauliffe today
the goal here is to drive a wedge and
say that black voters are being put upon
if you don't want to teach critical race
theory which is a lie it's not true and
it's not going to work it's not going to
work
mcauliffe has run an abysmal campaign
people are not interested in his
governance
he is running in a year where joe biden
is deeply unpopular and he's got a
problem he also happens to suck as a
container as a campaigner he's just bad
i mean his closing line is that glenn
youngkin wants to put kids in hospitals
and then he just blows the numbers
completely on how many kids are in
hospitals thanks to covet here it was
yesterday
we got to protect our students
today
1142 of our children have been
hospitalized with covet
uh no 19
kids are in the hospital right now
because of covet in all of virginia
yeah running a solid i wonder why he's
losing wonder we'll get some more of
this in just one second because again
parents have reason to worry about their
kids in virginia public schools we'll
get some more on that in just one second
first let's talk about a simple fact you
need a mattress that is made just for
you you personalize everything else in
your life right you go to a restaurant
and you don't want onions on the salad
you're going to tell the waiter about it
so how about that thing you spend eight
hours a day on that mattress shouldn't
that be personalized to you helix sleep
makes that happen they've got a quiz it
takes just two minutes to complete they
match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you why would you buy a mattress made
for somebody else with helix you're
getting a mattress you know will be
perfect for the way you sleep
everybody's unique helix knows that so
they have several different mattress
models to choose from they've got soft
medium and firm mattresses mattresses
great for cooling you down if you sleep
hot mattress is great for spinal
alignment to prevent morning aches and
pains even a helix plus mattress for
plus size sleepers so if you're looking
for a mattress you take the quiz you
order the mattress you match to the
mattress comes directly to your door
shipped for free you don't ever need to
go to a mattress store again you've got
a 10 year warranty you have to try it
out for 100 nights at risk free they'll
even pick it up for you if you don't
love it but you will helix even has
financing options and flexible payment
plans so a great night's sleep is never
far away just go to helixsleep.com ben
take their two minute sleep quiz they
will match you to a customized mattress
that will give you the best sleep of
your life helix is offering up to 200
bucks off your mattress order and two
free pillows for our
com listeners at
i love my helix sleep mattress you will
love your own go check them out right
now helix sleep.com slash ben from up to
200 bucks off your mattress order and
two free pillows alrighty so why our
parents are worried about loudoun county
new breaking story from luke rosiak
who's done unbelievable work at daily
wire reporting on loudoun county like
since the very beginning you need to
support us here at daily wire become a
member over at dailywire.com
using the promo code real news get 25
off do that because you need to support
our investigative reporting which has
made a big difference in this particular
race now luke has a new report quote
internal loudoun county school board
emails show a shifting explanation about
how much school board members knew about
a bathroom sex assault with one member
writing to the superintendent in the
wake of cover-up allegations that he
might have quote missed an email
informing him about it even though he
previously responded to that same email
asking a follow-up question after also
hearing about the incident from someone
else
so basically they're now claiming
ignorance when luke rosiak has the
receipt
from my memory i recall only learning
about it during the public comment
process democrat board member harris
mahedevi wrote to the superintendent on
october 12th one day after the daily
wear revealed the girl had been raped in
a bathroom on may 28th that the
superintendent had denied it in a public
board meeting june 22 and that the
school system had quietly transferred
the assailant to another school where he
was arrested for a different sex assault
on october 6th
as has been previously reported
immediately after the may rape ziegler
wrote to the school board member saying
the purpose of this email is to provide
you with information regarding an
incident that occurred at stonebridge
high school this afternoon a female
student alleged that a male student
sexually assaulted her in a restroom
three weeks later on june 22nd ziegler
said in a public board meeting that
quote to my knowledge we don't have any
record of assaults occurring in our
restrooms none of the school board
members raised the discrepancy but a
week after that on june 28th it was on
the mind of school board members that
the newly obtained email show
made every replied to the may 28th email
that day writing quote dr zigler has
there been any update on this case
ziegler replied the matter is under
investigation by law enforcement i'm
unable to provide an update that same
day school board member beth bart also
wrote the superintendent suggesting that
she'd heard of the sexual assault from
parents
she said in addition to understanding
where the loudoun county public schools
are in regards to allegations of sexual
assault i would like to know how lcps
will handle the rally on wednesday
zigler didn't address the question about
sexual assault but only informed her
he'd lock up the administration building
to make it unavailable to attendees in
the event of angry parents
bart subsequently announced her
resignation from the board
so that is not great
so so there they literally are saying
that they didn't know about it but they
were replying to emails specifically
about
the alleged sexual assault so they did a
wonderful job of protecting your kids
folks take control of your school boards
or get your kids out of public schools
those are your choices
really if you want to protect your kids
those are the two choices okay meanwhile
joe biden's plans are completely falling
apart
he before he left town last week to head
on overseas to hang out with the pope
and not talk about abortion and then go
to
cop26 and jabber about
climate change while falling asleep as
we'll get to in a moment joe manchin the
the president of the united states nacho
mansion joe biden drops a 1.75 trillion
dollar framework plan for buildback
better it was supposed to be half of the
price of the original 3.5 trillion
sticker there's only one problem it was
a lie a lot of the cost was still there
they were just creating false sunsets
they were saying what if we put this
plan in place the child tax credit for
one year
instead of budgeting it for 10 which
would cost a trillion bucks what if we
budget it for one year it'll cost 100
billion and then next year the democrats
will just re-up it
which is a way of simply reducing the
price tag
in the cbo estimates
okay well
the notion there was that throwing out
the framework would get progressives to
agree to the framework they would invite
they would then vote on the
infrastructure bill and then later they
would negotiate the rest of back better
then the progressives were like no we're
not going to do that we're going to vote
on both of these things at the same time
we don't trust that joe manchin and
christian cinema are even going to vote
for bill back better anyway
so we are going to instead hold up the
infrastructure bill in an attempt to
pressure mansion
okay so that was their tactic their
tactic is we're going to tie these two
things together if manchin wants his
infrastructure bill he's going to have
to pledge to vote for bill back better
well yesterday mansion came out and he's
like i'm not doing any of that
you're going to vote for infrastructure
or you're not going to vote for
infrastructure but bottom line is you
can't blackmail me on this
you have no reason to hold up
infrastructure because you actually like
that bill the only reason you're doing
that is to try and leverage me into
voting for a bill i don't particularly
like so you know what tough not gonna do
it here is joe manchin the de facto
president of the united states from west
virginia
i am urging
all of my colleagues in the house to
vote
and pass the bipartisan infrastructure
bill it's bipartisan 69 votes we worked
on that for many many months as i've
said before holding that bill hostage is
not going to work
to get my support
of what you want it's what we should all
agree on and work through the process
i'm open to supporting a final bill that
helps move our country forward but i am
equally open to voting against a bill
that hurts our country
okay so there he is actively ripping on
bill back better right he's saying the
bill back better plan hurts our country
now here's the thing that joe manchin
joe manchin is in the red estate in
america there is no political incentive
for him to vote for bill back better
none like zero even a scaled down
version if he votes for that he has to
go back home to his voters who hates joe
biden right this is the this is the
let's go brandon crowd over in west
virginia right they are all members of
the lgb community
and he has to go back to them and try to
explain to them why he voted for bill
back better say i'm not going to do that
vote for infrastructure or don't vote
for infrastructure but
tough padookies i ain't voting for bill
backpatter not under this false
framework here's mansion just dumping
all over it i for one won't support a
multi-trillion dollar bill without
greater clarity about why congress
chooses to ignore the serious effects of
inflation
and debt that have on our economy and
existing government programs for example
how can i in good conscience vote for a
bill that proposes
massive expansion to social programs
when vital programs like social security
and medicare face insolvency
and benefits could start being reduced
as soon as 2026 in medicare and 2033
in social security
how does that make sense and i don't
think it does
um ouch
so there's joe manchin just putting a
stake through joe biden's build-back
better now here's the thing about biden
you know to a certain extent i think
biden might have to be a little happy
that bill back better goes down in
flaming defeated joe manchin because the
reality is that the plan would be very
bad for the economy right it actually
would increase inflation it would
undermine work we don't have enough
people in the country working right now
right we have millions of open jobs and
so maybe it's better for biden if the
thing never passes the problem is
he got unlucky and democrats won those
two seats in georgia if they had a
minority in the senate he could be
yelling at mitch mcconnell right now and
said he has to yell at joe manchin
meanwhile the house progressives have
started to reverse course here is
pramila jayapal who basically said okay
you called my bluff
we are taking the president's word at um
the fact that he believes he can get 50
votes in the senate um and you know i
hope that the two senators uh that we've
been waiting on these months um who who
have come to the table in good faith and
negotiated that they understand that
this is a leap of faith but uh you know
assuming we get these these final
negotiations done we're ready to pass
uh both bills and i think the caucus
feels very good about the fact that
we've been able to do what we said from
the beginning okay except you didn't do
what you said from the beginning and
it's going to be fun to watch the
blowback on the progressive wing of the
party who said they were going to force
joe manchin into a corner and then
completely fail to do so because it
turns out they had no leverage they had
no leverage at all they could vote down
the infrastructure plan the minute they
voted it down joe manchin was going to
not vote for anything they wanted so
they really had no leverage over mansion
they thought they did and now the
progressives are basically running for
cover and so watch as the chenguer wing
of the party just goes to town on the
progressives
yeah
i wouldn't be surprised if if aoc and
the squad actively vote against the
infrastructure bill in the house see
it's not just a matter of what happens
in the senate where bernie has
threatened that he might not vote for
infrastructure but he probably will cave
there might be enough nuts in the in the
democratic side of the house not to get
to a majority and then nancy pelosi has
to rely on republicans to vote for the
infrastructure package which looks
pretty ugly for her
okay so all of this is just to
demonstrate that joe biden's
administration has been a failure in
pretty much every way in a second we'll
get some more failure from the joe biden
administration there's a reason why
glenn younkin is probably going to win
in virginia today and it has a lot to do
with what's happening at the national
level again joe biden is underwater
everywhere we'll get some more on this
like global warming has now affected his
poll numbers to the extent that the
water levels are rising and he has
completely submerged we'll get some more
of this in just one second first i am
thrilled to introduce an incredible app
everyone who buys gas needs to know
about get upside so you might have
checked out the sticker shock at the gas
station these days it is wild if you're
in california you might paying six bucks
a gallon seven bucks a gallon in some
places well wouldn't it be great to save
some money when you pump your gas my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now use promo code shapiro and get a
bonus 25 cents per gallon on your first
fill up that's up to 50 cents cash back
don't pay full price at the pump anymore
get cash back using get upside just
download the app for free use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank some people
who drive a lot are making as much as
two to three hundred dollars a month in
cash back there is no cash the cash back
it gets added directly to your account
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an e-gift card for
amazon and other brands just download
the free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your very first tank of gas
that is code shapiro and remember get
that get upside app for free over at the
app store use promo code shapiro get 50
cents per gallon cash back on your first
time great deal also daily wires growth
it's showing no signs of slowing down i
mean we have a lot coming man we have so
much content in the pipeline i can't
even i can't believe it honestly and we
are seeking exceptional candidates for
open positions across several
departments within the company to join
in our success as we continue to expand
our current list of open positions on
the team here at daily wire includes but
is not limited to you ready for this
podcast marketing manager content
coordinator publicity manager member
experience representative managing
editor sales representative producer and
analytics engineer it's a lot of open
jobs so if you are a young person
particularly looking to get into the
media industry and you've got some
background in any of these fields if
you're looking to move to a hot area
like nashville or if you want to work
for the show maybe south florida you
need to apply you owe it to yourself you
have to be young by the way as long as
you're well qualified come on down if
you think you've got what it takes to
join the fastest growing conservative
media company in america we want to hear
from you for a full list of open
positions and details and to apply
please visit dailywire.com
careers again dailywire.com some of you
will send me emails personally and i do
check them out and i try to forward them
but if you want to make sure that your
resume actually gets into the hopper go
check out dailywire.com
careers you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
meanwhile the biden administration which
is failing on pretty much every front
has decided to fail harder
according to hot air.com the labor
department is now going to publish their
federal vaccine mandate within days now
one of the things that we've seen across
the country is that vaccine mandates
have led to wild shortages in everything
from health care to
policing to fire departments and yet joe
biden is still going to try and ram
through this labor department mandate
via osha good luck
it was announced by the labor department
this week the federal register will be
publishing the final details of joe
biden's vaccine mandate with employers
with more than 100 employees this is
done after the office of management and
budget completed its mandatory review of
the new rule this morning the rule is
expected to impact more than 100 million
employees nationwide it's being referred
to as an emergency temporary standard
assuming you believe they have anything
they have to say at this point
of course the options being offered to
non-government employers are different
than those in some but not all parts of
the government that shouldn't come as
any surprise because consistency hasn't
really been a thing according to cnn a
labor department spokesperson said on
november 1st the office of management
and budget completed its regulatory
review of the ets the federal register
will publish the emergency temporary
standard in the coming days the
occupational safety and health
administration has been working
expeditiously to develop an emergency
temporary standard that covers employers
with 100 or more employees firm or
company-wide and provides options for
compliance now i will note here again
this policy makes no sense
if you're going to cram down a vaccine
mandate it should be completely
universal right why is it only
restricted to companies with over 100
employees
really it turns out that covet is
generally being passed in small areas if
you have a company with over 100
employees there's a good chance that
your offices are rather large our
offices in nashville are very large we
have a couple hundred employees over
there probably a better chance that
you're going to be spreading it in a
very small space at a smallest but
they're not targeting small businesses
because they know about the blowback
the spokesperson added covered employee
employers must develop implement and
enforce a mandatory covenant 19
vaccination policy unless they adopt a
policy requiring employees to choose
either to get vaccinated or to undergo
regular covenant testing and wear a face
covering at work the ets also requires
employers to provide paid time to
workers to get vaccinated and paid sick
leave to recover from any side effects
so
this is um this is not going to hold up
we first of all as as we've said at
daily wire we are not going to abide by
this we plan to challenge this in court
literally the day that this is
promulgated we at the daily wire along
with our legal allies will be pushing
back against it
the policy internally makes no sense
all over the country the state has not
been allowing employees to test or mask
as an alternative so only in the private
sector apparently
and again the rule is now including a
demand that employers not only offer
paid time off to get vaccinated but pay
for any recovery time
i mean when was the last time that if
you got a flu shot did your employer pay
you for the for the flu shot time off
and also this is not an emergency
temporary standard so there's a good
shot this thing gets struck down in
court but again it's joe biden just
trying to be able to say that that he's
keeping his promises here's the problem
the people on the left seem to think
that when joe biden keeps his promises
it makes him more popular what if when
joe biden keeps his promises it makes
him less popular because his promises
suck how about that
new polling shows according to nbc news
that more people oppose the vaccine
mandates than favor the vaccine mandates
i said this all along i said that the
early polling that showed that vaccine
mandates were popular that was because a
lot of the people who were in favor of
vaccine mandates were already vaccinated
but then it dawned on them wait a second
if there are vaccine mandates i might
have to get a booster maybe i don't want
to get a booster
if there are vaccine mandates what if
that means there's no stuff on the
shelves of the store where i want to buy
things what if it means that i call 911
and no cop shows up
so now 47 favor of the vaccine mandates
50 opposed but here's the more important
stat only 34 of americans strongly favor
a vaccine mandate as opposed to 41 who
strongly oppose the vaccine mandate
remember when i said that the only
people who are passionate about these
issues are the people who oppose correct
okay so joe biden seems to make the
common mistake of looking at poll
numbers and believing that because
people say they like a thing it's a high
priority for them and that is not the
same thing at all
speaking of things where people say that
they are interested in it but they're
really not interested in it this brings
us to joe biden and the climate
conference which we're supposed to all
pretend is super important even though
china and russia are not there and china
is the world's leading emitter
cop 26 the united nations the most
eisley of international politics a
wretched hive of scum and villainy
according to the wall street journal
president biden told world leaders at
the cop26 summit that the coming decade
would be decisive in the fight against
climate change wow
wow he said it would be decisive
uh incredible i mean i'm like i'm
stunned by the amount of bravery that
took stunning bravery with brave
stunningness
hours later indian prime minister
narendra modi gave a slower than
expected deadline for slashing his
country's emissions saying india would
take as long as 2070 to reduce its net
greenhouse gases to zero
oh you mean because they wish to develop
and carbon is cheap you mean you mean
that
oh
oops so joe biden's like this is the
okay that matters we have to save the
and then meanwhile in india which is
admitting at crazy rates like
what if we just wait until 2070.
what you gonna do about it joe what are
you going to do about it
the gap according to the wall street
journal highlights a fundamental divide
between developing and developed nations
days after leaders of the group of 20
major economies made little progress
hammering out specific climate goals
many had hoped would ease discussions in
scotland
speaking to leaders and government
officials from most of the world's
nations mr biden warned that none of us
can escape the worst that is yet to come
the doomsday cult that is the climate
change movement is really crazy
we'll never escape really we've escaped
literally for all of human history we
have adapted the human species to
changing climate we are now better
equipped to adapt to changing climate
than at any time in human history which
is why climate deaths year on year
continue to drop even though the climate
is indeed changing
but we have to pretend that the only way
to prevent the bad effects of climate
change is to prevent climate change
itself by completely crippling the
economy
and so we're just going to alarm you
into do but my favorite thing is when
joe biden is trying to alarm you into
doing things by using extraordinarily
purple language and then when it comes
down to what are you actually willing to
do joe he's like well we do need cheaper
gas here is joe biden at cop26
explaining this is an existential threat
to humanity it is not an existential
threat to humanity literally no one
who's worth their salt in this area
believes that climate change is going to
wipe human beings off planet earth no
one believes that that's crazy talk
here's joe biden engaging in some crazy
talk that again because we live in a
crazy era is taken seriously
right now
we're still falling short
there's no more time to hang back or sit
in the fence or argue amongst ourselves
this is the challenge of our collective
lifetimes
the existential threat threat to human
existence as we know it
and every day we delay
the cost of inaction increases
so let this be the moment that we answer
history's call here in glasgow let this
be the moment when we answer yeah good
luck with that but and then he says it's
an inflection point in world history all
this bloviating honestly the carbon
emissions coming out of this dude's
mouth are going to change the climate by
a couple of degrees celsius over the
course of the next century
within the growing catastrophe
i believe there's an incredible
opportunity
not just for the united states but for
all of us
we're standing at an inflection point in
world history
we have the ability to invest in
ourselves and build an equitable clean
energy future and in the process create
millions of good playing jobs and
opportunities around the world
yeah okay if anybody believes by the way
the green energy sector is going to make
up for the carbon sector right now you
are out of your mind no one believes
this if that were the case by the way
then the investment community would have
already dumped money into this area to
the extent that we would already be
transforming and in some areas we are
right i mean we already have teslas
right
like electric cars aren't going to be a
thing but here's the thing cars are
actually not the chief source of
emissions when it comes to climate
actual power plants are the chief source
of a mission when it comes to climate
and developing nations need those
and then joe biden went on to apologize
for donald trump pulling out of the
paris agreement as though the paris
agreement meant to anything i do like
john kerry the easter island head behind
joe biden
the the old white face of the
anti-climate change movement is really
uh really always astonishingly inspiring
i guess i shouldn't apologize but i do
apologize for the fact the united states
uh
the last administration pulled out of
the paris accords and put us sort of
behind
people
the first thing i did was like to
see my friend nadia said over
yeah i put us back in the useless
agreement that didn't do anything
i mean nobody kept to it but it was but
i hate trump so you know
okay so all this is so exciting and so
necessary and so deeply moving joe i
mean joe biden is so
there for it he is so on the mark he is
like if called upon he will spring to
his feet he will answer the call this is
the inflection point we have to prevent
the catastrophe of a world boiling
itself to death
joe biden fell asleep
like actually fell asleep in the middle
of one of these climate change
conferences
you can see him there he is eyes start
to close
and joe biden is gone he is now sleeping
in the middle of this conference there
he is he is clearly out he's clearly out
cold like my baby in the back seat of
the car in a long drive joe biden is
gone he is just
slow in fact joe biden had to be woken
up by an aide to clap at the end of the
speech i am not kidding you that is a
thing that actually happened
our daughtering elderly pr again
the the face of a decaying west is joe
biden
a career politician who's never done a
productive thing in his entire life
who is now the president of the united
states pledging to destroy
the fundamental institutions of the west
ranging from family to free market in
order to achieve a utopian vision that
will never be achieved but will maximize
the power of old people like joe biden
like that that is that is
he's a pretty good metaphor he is just
like as a human he's just a good
metaphor for what's happening
right now
by the way the the same joe biden
who is suggesting that we have reached
the end that it's all over we've reached
the end uh he's seeking more oil
production according to the new york
times
oops
days earlier according to the new york
times he was urging the world's largest
oil producers to pump more
the incongruity was on center stage both
at the global climate summit currently
taking place in scotland and in rome
this past weekend during a gathering of
leaders from the 20 largest economies
according to the new york times the
president's comments highlighted the
political and economic realities facing
politicians as they grapple with climate
change on the surface it seems like an
irony said biden but the truth of the
matter is you've all known everybody
knows the idea we're going to be able to
move to renewable energy overnight was
just not rational
um
you could
let the pumping slow and raise the
prices and let your constituents suffer
you could do that if you are joe biden
now you could do that but then you'd
bear the political brunt he's not
willing to do that which is amazing for
a guy who says we have to have the
courage to move into a new tomorrow
it's super important move into a new
tomorrow
meanwhile by the way the tech community
is mobilizing on behalf of the
propaganda as poor as per usual
arrangement according to the washington
post twitter now says that they are
going to attempt to combat climate
disinformation by steering its massive
user base to reliable information with
more context a strategy the company
calls pre-bunking
or
you could go with just propagandizing
the rollout coincides with the uncop 26
climate summit in glasgow scotland by
the way that is not going to make people
suspicious of the institutional powers
that be at all when you coordinate what
information people can see we won't be
we'll probably believe you probably we
won't be suspicious at all that maybe
this is part of a larger plan to reshape
the institutions of the planet
twitter uses will be directed to online
hubs containing credible authoritative
information according to a company blog
post these guides will appear in users
explore tabs their twitter search
portals and relevant trends lists
according to a twitter spokesperson the
platform wants to get ahead of any
coordinated falsehoods that could
surface during the summit which aims to
chart an aggressive course to cut
greenhouse gas emissions and slow
earth's warming
so the company spokesperson says they
need reliable authoritative hubs of
information from global experts
yeah i'm sure that'll go well
whenever you have our institutional
bettors telling you what you can and
cannot see and how you ought to think
about crucial issues that affect your
life
that definitely fosters trust
the belief by all these people that the
more they control your life the more you
trust them is totally crazy but it is
something that they continue to double
down on over and over and over again on
everything from education to climate
change i am gratified to see that i'm
not the only one who's calling out cop26
i have to say i'm very gratified to see
that
so
greta turnburg one of the great heroines
of our time
greta tunberg is basically
like jesus in every single conceivable
way except for none of them but she is a
little child will lead them and she's no
longer a child she's an adult so i can
make fun of her as much as i want
and uh and greta tunberg appeared
outside of the summit the cop 26 summit
literally her entire job in life is just
to run around yelling at the adults the
adults have disappointed us you're you
have disappointed greta greta's
disappointed in you
except when she's dancing ecstatically
to rick astley greta's very upset with
you i i honestly don't know what greta's
gonna do with her life when she hits
like 50.
like what do you do at that point you
just yell at the 80 year olds or do you
start yelling at the children in which
case you're just an adult
like right now the the charm and wonder
of greta tunberg is that she was a very
young person and now she's only a
moderately young person yelling at the
adults i feel like by the time she's 23
the magic has worn off a little bit here
but greta tonenberg did say but it's
true she says inside here they're all
just they're all just speaking words
verbiage that means nothing nothing
and uh and so she uh went off on the
climate conference she's not wrong
inside cope they're just politicians and
people in power pretending to take our
future seriously to pretending to take
the presence seriously of the people who
are being affected already today by the
climate crisis
change is not going to come from inside
there that is not leadership this is
leadership
i i like when she declares herself later
that's fun change is not going to come
from wordly to saying things it's from
me in a field with seven of you say
that's where leadership really comes in
uh
it's so that was pretty that was pretty
great i i enjoyed that the best part is
when she starts cursing at the adults
not the adults it's it's pretty great uh
so um here she continues around she's
again she's not wrong all the people who
are inside there are pretending to care
about climate change
but don't care enough to actually do
anything because they understand the
reality of the world which is that there
are costs and benefits to policies and
that the benefits when it comes to
radically redefining how the world
economy works
radically
underestimate the cost the cost is way
greater in the near term and the midterm
and the long term if you take the sorts
of drastic action that people like greta
would like you for you to take you
actually wrecked the world economy and
you set the world back a couple hundred
years
all to please a a nordic child who's no
longer a child who's now an adult so she
can just vote like everybody else and
then her voice would be equivalent to
everybody else's
so uh but but here she was going off on
on the adults as usual i'm never going
to to stop being pleased that greta is
disappointed in all of us i just think
it's it it's great she's like a prophet
of old and just stands there and talks
about how disappointing like prophets in
the old days they used to say that god
is disappointed in you because you're
sinning
and now greta says that she is
disappointed in you it's not that god is
disappointed she is disappointed in you
and so long as credit
i honestly i need to wear a bracelet
that says
w w
gtd what would greta tundra do or
i
gt
d
i y
is greta tunde disappointed in you
here
again folks i can make fun of her as
much as i damn well please she's an
adult i've been waiting for like a
couple of years to do this because i
know the rules i know the rules but now
now all bets are off here's greta
thonberg yelling and cursing about uh
about the adults in the room inside
those bastards
we say no more blah blah blah no more
exploitation of people and nature and
the planets no more exploitation
no more blah blah blah
mama whatever they're doing inside there
ah she cursed no more blah blah blah i
want an oompa loompa daddy i want it now
i want one
i want the world i want the whole world
i
i i want a party with rooms for of
laughter 10 000 tons of ice cream
i want to wear like braids in my hair i
don't want to share them give it to me
now
and i love that the old people was like
and then joe biden like joe biden when
asked about greta thunderbird and all
this nonsense i just i'll never get over
it i'll never get over the old people
who are actually charged with balancing
the competing interests and then
never watch what they say watch what
they do actually act like rational human
beings when it comes to say pumping gas
because people need gas you get in their
cars and go to work and such
i'll never get over the old people
humoring this
so it's like greta dunberg being like
you old man
why aren't you doing what i say
you you bastard what no more blah blah
blah
i i i understand what you're saying and
also um i would like to uh sniff your
hair
i don't want you to sniff my hair old
man blah blah no more blah blah blah
and your buttons like no never gonna
give you a shake i do love that song
let's dance together for the planet for
the planet
you know what
you know what now i'm after after this
whole thing i'm just rooting for global
warming i've got to be honest with you
i'm rooting for global warming it's got
to take all of us out because something
does we have a civilization with a death
wish and uh and the longer we humor
corrupt old daughtering idiots and small
children who don't know anything about
the world uh the the uh the worst things
are going to get so
now i'm rooting for global warming i'm
on global warming side now so i'm just
gonna go outside i'm just gonna let my
car idle in the driveway for like a
couple of years for no reason because
humanity deserves it like it we just we
deserve it all right we reached the end
of today's show
we will be back here later today with an
additional hour of content in the
meantime coming up soon as the matt wall
show airing at 1 30 p.m eastern also if
you're in virginia go vote for glenn
young can against the idiot terry
mcauliffe be sure to check it out over
at dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the bench bureau show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show